18 und fragmente eines unterkiefers ein
fund in der sogenannten müssen die höhle
im karmel-gebirge der forschungsteams
staunen lässt denn die bislang ältesten
überreste des homo sapiens außerhalb von
afrika verraten damit überraschende
erkenntnisse zum leben und der
wanderrouten der modernen menschen im
klartext die bekannte out of africa
theorie also die theorie wie die
menschen aus afrika gekommen sind muss
wohl neu geschrieben werden
ihr habt euch dieses thema in der
whatsapp community gewünscht link am
ende des videos und bekommt jetzt alle
interessanten effekt zu diesem
überraschungs kunden in klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
ja vielleicht hat das auch noch so im
geschichtsunterricht gelernt nach
bisherigen erkenntnissen entstand der
homo sapiens vor rund 300.000 jahren in
afrika
doch die bislang ältesten fossilen funde
die eindeutig dem homo sapiens
zuzuordnen sind sind nur rund 160000
jahre alt doch genetische hochrechnungen
ließen forschungsteams weltweit dennoch
von der entstehung unserer vorfahren vor
rund 300.000 jahren ausgehen vor etwa 60
bis 120 tausend jahren soll der moderne
mensch laut der sogenannten out of
africa theorie dann afrika verlassen
haben das zeigen funde aus dieser zeit
die aktuellen funde aus der höhle die
nur einige kilometer von der hafenstadt
haifa entfernt ist wegen jetzt aber nahe
dass die menschlichen vorfahren schon
sehr viel früher afrika den rücken
gekehrt haben nämlich ganze 50.000 jahre
vorher als bisher gedacht also von
mindestens 177 1000 jahren
das forschungsteam von der universität
tel aviv hat mit verschiedenen
platzierungs methoden gearbeitet und so
das alter der acht zähne und oberkiefer
fragmente bestimmt unterschiedliche
methoden die in verschiedenen
untersuchungen und laboren angewandt
worden ergaben übereinstimmende und
wirklich beeindruckende erkenntnisse
demnach haben die fossilien ein alter
zwischen 177 1194 1000 jahre der
aktuelle fund stützt übrigens eine
studie aus dem vergangenen jahr eines
forschungsteams vom max-planck-institut
für menschheitsgeschichte in jena
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler hatten aufgrund einer
gen analyse die hypothese aufgestellt
dass der moderne mensch früher als
bisher angenommen
afrika verlassen hatte nämlich vor etwa
200.000 jahren die neue studie stützt
zudem weitere aktuelle erkenntnisse von
evolution szenegängern ein
forschungsteam aus leipzig hat dem
letzten jahr dna untersuchungen gemacht
die nahelegen dass sich die wege von
homo sapiens und neandertaler schon 430
bis 145 1000 jahren gekreuzt hatten zur
info etwa vier prozent des menschlichen
erbguts stammen von neandertalern also
ließ schon dieses schuljahrs leipzig
vermuten dass sich der homo sapiens
bereits 230.000 jahren außerhalb von
afrika herumgetrieben hat und es dort
eben auch zu sexuellen konnte
packen kann doch der aktuelle von
korrigiert nicht nur die out of africa
theorie sondern gibt auch hinweise
darauf wie die modernen menschen von ost
afrika nach asien gelangen sind denn
dazu werden zwei routen diskutiert der
eine weg führt über ägypten und die
sinai-halbinsel die andere route führt
vom heutigen äthiopien über die
arabische halbinsel
der jetzt entdeckte fundort spricht
dafür dass der homo sapiens wohl
zunächst über das niltal kam es war der
beginn der besiedlung der gesamten erde
durch den menschen den homo sapiens es
ist jetzt also noch früher passiert und
vielleicht gibt es da bald noch mehr und
noch genauere erkenntnisse wenn er als
erstes neues zu diesem thema zu allen
anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an dann
schicke ich euch vor allen anderen einen
link zum neuesten video garantiert ihr
könnt dort auch direkt in der redaktion
von krieg so mitmachen und themen
vorschlagen oder fragen zu videos
stellen es ist quasi der direkte draht
zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und
natürlich nicht das abo mit der glocke
ihr wisst genau vergessen hier geht es
weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken der
mensch ist hunderttausend jahre älter ja
das passt auch zu den neuesten
erkenntnissen an sonst würde ich mal
sagen bis dann bleibt dran